so you're out Annie is a potty thinking
of kissing someone at midnight let's try
some other traditions like the ones
involving snacks because we get hungry
excuse me Peter take spank where they
eat a grape for every Bell that strikes
at midnight whoa slow down Sam it's just
12 even more delicious Switzerland they
eat whipped cream it's customary to let
some spill on the floor if you're
looking for something more healthy look
to Chile they eat a spoonful of lentils
at midnight oh yeah lentils okay to
healthy how about the Netherlands the
Dutch eats special sugary doughnuts but
it's better shared with friends okay I
know what you're thinking
where's the bruise enter Russia then
it's customary to write your wishes down
and burn the paper the ashes then
dropped into some bubbles and drink hmm
ah she's so hungry in Japan mate
buckwheat noodles which represent
longevity and wet
speaking of wealth if you're the lucky
one to find the coin in this traditional
Greek bread you'll promise good luck for
the next year
yay looks like Kimberly's in pretty idea
but something that's found around the
world good cheer good friends and maybe
a few great big stars
you